okay guys
so we'll just kick this off real quick
joyce is here so we got you
and you're on here right phil yep
[Music]
all right um ready to go
all right we'll call this to order we'll
call this to order
thank you everybody for joining us here
today we are the
problem solvers caucus uh and as you
know and
has been reported the last few days we
came together
as a caucus working with our senate
partners on a
bipartisan bicameral 908 billion dollar
covid
relief package that we are here
today to discuss again to say that we
made substantial
progress even from the last uh two two
days
uh from where we were at uh we are
gaining momentum
uh as we speak uh we had senator john
thune
uh shelly moore capito and kevin kramer
all came out here recently
on the republican side in the senate
speaking favorably
of the 908 billion dollar package i know
on the democratic side
we had speaker pelosi and leader schumer
offer
positive comments about the 908 billion
dollar
uh package we are moving in the right
direction i had extensive conversations
last night
with corey gardner this is becoming one
of his
top priorities uh in the senate as he
leaves the senate to make sure that this
gets done
before he leaves so i encourage you to
reach out to cory gardner
himself and ask him his thoughts as he
works with leadership
in the senate to push this to the finish
line
to get signed into law and get the
american people
and the american businesses the relief
that they need that's represented by
this 908 billion dollars
that we're talking about now as we go
forward
i got to tell you this wouldn't have
happened without the leadership
of the folks here in the problem solvers
caucus so i want to thank my co-chair
josh gottheimer but most importantly i
want to thank each and every one of
these members
that came together and we were able to
support this package because of the work
and the relationship and the trusting
relationship
that this group has formed over the last
years working together
and putting the american people first
not shedding
the fact that we are proud republicans
that we are proud democrats
but at the end of the day we know who we
work for and that is
those are the people back home the
people that we are listening to
that we care deeply about and i got to
tell you the leadership team
that helped put this together people
like dusty johnson
anthony gonzalez fred upton on the
republican side
abigail spamberger dean phillips and
my good friend josh gottheimer on the
democratic side i guess got to tell you
it was hours upon hours of working
together
listening to each other and coming up
with that sweet spot
and common ground that's represented
with this package
and so without further ado i want to
give my co-chair
josh godheimer the opportunity to say a
few words josh tom
first i just want to thank you so much
tom for your excellent leadership
and i i just want to echo tom's words
every single
member behind me was part of making this
happen and our tiger team the excellent
leadership as mentioned of dean and
dusty and anthony
and abigail uh and fred you i mean we're
talking around the clock
working with our senate colleagues for
weeks including on thanksgiving day
because that's how important it is to
actually not just stand here
but now to get this across the finish
line and that's what we're all focused
on
it's why we're working with our senate
colleagues republican and democrat
and with leaderships really just saying
to them this is our moment
to get this done for the american people
we simply cannot afford
to wait and i the support has been
overwhelming you've seen everyone from
the chamber to the retail federation
to the airlines obviously scores of
groups who care about
feeding families because that's a key
part of this and making sure we get
state and local aid
to our struggling communities and
unemployment to our families we're
hurting as we go into the holiday season
here
and covet spiking 200 000 cases a day
we know the reason why this is critical
we will not
leave washington until we get this done
that's our position we're not going
anywhere so we're going to keep sitting
down with our leadership
and making it clear to them we've got to
make this happen the momentum is
building as tom said
and again not just one side of the aisle
from both sides of the aisle our whole
belief in the problem solvers caucus is
putting country first
not democrat or republican first but the
united states of america it's why we're
here
and then we work together every single
week the 50 of us 25 democrats
and 25 republicans to actually get
things done
and that's i know every one of my
colleagues you're gonna hear from that's
why they're here
and that's how this plan came together
now we're still working we're in the
drafting phases right now the
legislation that's what's going
on with calls again this morning with
our senate colleagues sitting down with
them
to make it happen it's going to happen
around the clock for the next days
until we get a bill out there it will
get passed because we're going to fight
every single day to make sure it happens
so i can't thank my colleagues enough i
can't thank my
co-chair enough in this team because
this is what the model of governing
should be about
working together for the country we
represent so now
i'm going to turn it over to abigail
spamberger
who's a whip of the problem service
caucus and has done a phenomenal job
over the last
weeks helping pull this together abigail
thank you very much to my colleagues
here thank you to our colleagues on the
senate side
as josh godheimer noted we spoke every
single day including on thanksgiving day
though i did miss
the thanksgiving day call because i was
volunteering
at an event in central virginia called
the giving heart it's an event where
hundreds of volunteers come together
year after year
to deliver a wonderful thanksgiving meal
to families in need
to deliver resources flu shots donations
to people who
desperately need that support and if
hundreds upon hundreds of volunteers
can come together in time of crisis to
keep that tradition alive to feed
so many more hungry families across
central virginia
then congress damn well better come
together and deliver the relief that is
so necessary frankly relief that was
necessary
weeks and months ago but today is just
as good a day as any to actually see it
through
those of us who are here today represent
millions of americans
and among those americans there are
hungry families parents without jobs and
thousands of small business owners
who are on the verge of closing down
everything they have worked
to create and lay off the employees who
depend on them
they're staring down a holiday season
marked by tremendous uncertainty
and they're staring down the expiration
of critical assistance programs
congress cannot leave them behind we
must
act our proposal is negotiated to
provide them
with the relief that they need and
deserve
our proposal is focused on the families
the children the students
the public servants and small business
owners like restaurant owners throughout
the communities we represent
they are at the center of this proposal
and while there will be additional
necessary steps
that we will take in the future that we
will debate and work hard
to get across the finish line in the
future this package represents an
opportunity to recognize the threat
posed by the winter surge that we face
now in virginia we're seeing the
increasingly dire effects of this surge
covet 19 positivity in virginia is now
at 8.3 percent
it was at 5 percent just a few weeks ago
and just yesterday
the commonwealth of virginia reported
the highest numbers of hospitalizations
since the pandemic began nearly 15 000
virginians have been hospitalized during
this crisis
and yet in the seventh district we
continue to see heartbreaking
challenges facing our community members
including another devastating outbreak
at one of our long-term care facilities
we are in an emergency and while
congress acted swiftly earlier in the
year to deliver negotiated relief
it has failed in the months since
to continue to provide relief to
american families american workers
and american small business owners and
this continued moment of desperate need
the day for a relief proposal was in
fact yesterday and yesterday it was the
day before that and the day before that
but we have to act we have to act and as
republicans and as democrats
and his house members and our colleagues
on the senate we have now seen people
coming together
voicing their support for our proposal
and we have a clear opportunity to
act to finally act and to deliver the
much
needed relief that so many across our
communities
the millions who we represent deserve
and need right now
thank you very much for being here today
and i will
refer back to my colleague mr gothimer
next up is
fred upton from the great state of
michigan
well thanks josh and tom for your
leadership and
i just want to say with apologize with
apologies to my
coal state members i don't want to leave
coal in everybody's
pocket across the country at christmas
time because of our failure
to take action that has to happen
two things that really drive us here
i've got hospitals in my district that
are 100 percent full
and predictions are that it's going to
double again in two weeks where are they
going to go
where are they going to find the workers
we have to get this thing done
as i talk to my small businesses they're
they're struggling
a lot of them did get a ppp loan last
spring
but now they're faced those that
survived and we have hundreds and
hundreds across the country that filed
for bankruptcy
now they're faced with the prospect of
paying taxes
on those loans that they never that
became grants that they never thought
they're going to have to pay taxes on
it is worse than before
this legislation fixes that
and that's why all of us are behind it
we can't go home for christmas until we
get this thing done
and next on the list is a fellow member
of the tiger team
really good guy who really was driven to
get this thing done with his passion
dean phillips from minnesota
hey everybody um say it louder there's a
japanese proverb that says
vision without action is just a daydream
and we've had enough daydreaming
in this institution i've got photos here
of thousands of cars in line in dallas
texas
waiting for food many of them probably
filled with children
forty percent of whom have never been to
a food bank before
my other hand i've got a photo of people
in my own hometown of minneapolis
in line for food and it's not 1933 in
america it's damn it it's 2020 in the
united states of america we're standing
in front of a temple of democracy
behind me and i think our founders would
be ashamed of us
right now ashamed of us the inability
to do the most basic human necessary
work
for the most prosperous extraordinary
country that this globe has ever
known but i come here not to condemn
anybody rather to extend an invitation
to all the americans who might be
watching this
and who are wondering if they can have
faith in government anymore
if this place could ever operate again i
understand why you might ask that
but i also ask you to look at my
brothers and sisters behind me
democrats and republicans from all
around the country
with varying backgrounds and life
experiences and different political
perspectives
but remarkably unified in doing what's
best for this country and i am
so proud to be part of this group
because we are trying
and my invitation is to everybody else
in the three buildings behind you and on
the other side of this one behind me
to come together and do the most basic
of basics for the people in our country
that's what our founders would have
expected and as the world watches the
united
states of america right now after the
recent election
and they wonder about our democracy
right now let's give them
a reason to believe it works that's why
i'm here that's why my brothers and
sisters are here god bless america
thanks everybody
that's enough is dusty johnson
so last week 778 thousand americans
filed for unemployment benefits for the
first time
and last week ten thousand americans
died from covet 19.
and in that kind of an environment
inaction is inexcusable
i like my colleagues talk to nurses to
researchers to
nursing home employees to tribes to
families to landlords to ag producers
to teachers to hotel workers and when i
talk to those people
those people who are working hardest
during this pandemic they make it clear
that a focused and a targeted relief
package would help them do their jobs
would help them triumph over covet 19.
targeted focused that's what we're
talking about today
this framework doesn't have dozens of
unrelated provisions
half of the money is repurposed from
unspent cares act funding this is not a
difficult proposition
this is relief that this country needs
it is targeted
it is focused i believe it's necessary i
believe that it will get done
and when it gets done let there be no
question who jump started these
negotiations
it is the problem solvers caucus it will
have been because of the courage
and the hard work and the dedication of
the men and women who are gathered here
today
who were not willing to take no for an
answer
we are close we know that every hour
another
political leader stands up and adds
their voice to ours
we are dedicated to get this done
a key leader in this process has been
the hard-working and dedicated
uh lady from virginia congresswoman
elaine luria
good job
good afternoon and i joined here today
with my colleagues both
democrats and republicans um as part of
the problem solvers caucus and you've
heard
the hard work the hard work that our
tiger team my colleague abigail
spanberger also from virginia
and dusty and dean and everyone is put
into this package because people
need this they need this help
they are looking to their government to
their representatives to provide those
resources to get through the
largest economic and public health
crisis that we have seen in our lifetime
and as a member of the problem solvers
caucus like my colleagues here today
i'm proud to stand up and say that that
we are here working together
in a bipartisan way and with our
colleagues in the senate
to make this happen and to get people
the help that they need
and i echo what's been said here today
we cannot go home for the holidays
without providing that help
to people in our communities around the
country who may not
have a holiday may not have even the
money to buy their children their
grandchildren a gift or are worried
about the roof over their head because
an eviction is looming or can't even buy
that christmas turkey to put on the
table
we know that americans need our help and
i'm proud to be part of this group that
is working
to help make that happen for you across
america
and i would like to next uh bring up uh
tom swazi another member of the problem
solvers
caucus who's been working very hard on
this effort thank you elaine
i also want to thank josh and tom for
their great work of the tiger team for
all the efforts they put in here
the effects of this pandemic are cruelly
uneven some individuals some businesses
they're unscathed they've hardly been
affected
other people are completely wiped out
and unfortunately too many people living
in a beltway fantasyland
have been immune from the cries for help
that we all hear in our districts
we hear people they call us they're
desperate
they can't pay their rent they can't
they pay their utility bills
they're on food bank lines as you've
heard they're closing down their
restaurant they're closing down a
catering hall they're closing down their
live entertainment venue
mom and pop stores are going out of
business sure they're great retailers
online retailers are doing great
but other people have been laid off from
the airlines
so we've got to finally recognize
that we've got a job to do in the united
states government
this is our most basic function is to
help our country
to help our people to help our
businesses
get through this dark winter ahead of us
i've been one of the strongest advocates
for more
i wanted more money for state and local
aid i wanted more money
to be put in for so many different
things in this package
but i like the rest of our problem
solvers here and the senators that are
working together with us
recognize we need the help now before
christmas
we can't wait till february or march the
devastation will be too dramatic
so i want to thank everybody who's
worked so hard on this who've
put their country first and uh
let's keep on pushing to get this done
before christmas we can't go home
without getting this done
and with that i want to introduce my
co-vice chair and a great guy
brian fitzpatrick
every single one of us here know not
just my colleagues behind me but all of
you
how any functional relationship in our
lives work
you listen more than you lecture you
view diversity of thought as a strength
to be harnessed not a weakness to be
criticized you don't allow the perfect
to be the enemy of the good
and you take a belief that you'd rather
have eighty percent of something than a
hundred percent of nothing
that's how any functional relationship
in any of our lives works
that is not how this place works that's
how we work that's how we function
that's how you all function in your
lives that is not how this institution
works right now
so if you can sense the anger and the
frustration in our voices it's real
because it's echoing the anger and
frustrations that we're hearing when we
go back home
all of us represent a little bit over
700 000 constituents back home and i
know they're hearing the same thing i am
you have people that are on death's
doorstep both from a health standpoint
and an economic standpoint
that are begging for us to do a very
very basic function
which is to come to the center build
consensus and move forward
it's how anything that works in our
lives operates
on a normal basis and that's what we're
trying to do is restore sanity to this
institution
and there are 50 of us now if there were
218
of us in that institution and if any one
of us from either party were in house
leadership
you wouldn't have this gridlock you
would not have it because we
operate in a very very common sense
pragmatic rational reasonable
uh methodical way to not allow
anything um extraneous to block
progress so that we can get something
across the finish line and that's what
we're here for so
uh kudos to my colleagues democrat and
republican
we are not just colleagues we're friends
we stand with each other behind each
other
and uh we're hopeful we're not going
anywhere until we get something done
uh yeah vice chair uh straight are you
here sir
when we started the problem solvers
eight years ago
we hoped this day would come
over the years we've had a a
a great time working up and developing
these relationships you've heard about
here today
things that were unknown when i came to
the united states congress
those relationships breed trust
and they bring good legislation
we had a huge impact in the humanitarian
aid at the border
two years ago that deal came together
because the problem solvers
over the last two years we've tried to
broaden our reach beyond just house
members
reach out to the senate the united
states of america and we found willing
partners
folks that are also interested in being
problem solvers
big push came together uh the tiger team
kudos to them the rest of the members
here reached out to
senators both sides of the aisle get
them engaged what could actually pass
what could we get done
for the american people before the end
of this year
to help them through the toughest of
crises we've seen in my lifetime
and they responded and since you have
the legislation
here before you it's a framework it
hopefully helps our leadership
understand what members are willing to
go for
what the parameters are and i think
that's key that's key to helping
leadership do its job
i'm hopeful that they'll take it up in
the next week or so we need to get this
done
i agree we shouldn't go home for
christmas without making sure
there's a christmas for every american
and jimmy
thank you uh to let me let me just start
off by obviously thanking tom
and josh and the other members of the
tiger team that worked so hard
uh with our senate colleagues to put
this together
this is how things need to work in the
117th going forward it
is how things need to work today i want
to
also show my appreciation for the
incoming administration that is
prioritizing pandemic relief
but we can't wait till january 20th we
can't wait
till next week we can't wait till
tomorrow why
because this pandemic is exploding our
hospitals
are bursting and our economy is hurting
you have 11 million people who are going
to lose unemployment benefits
you have 26 million people who are
facing
food security and you have millions of
renters
student loan borrowers and families
whose benefits are going to run out
soon enough this is a time for us to
come together
as you've seen this was also a time
just last month in which those same
people
showed their faith in the democratic
process by coming out in record numbers
to vote and showing their belief in our
democracy
they gave us their votes it's our turn
to give us this funding to help them
fight
this disease to get through this dark
winter
and so that we can recover in spring
thank you
i'd like to introduce to you good friend
of mine
john catko thank you very much thank you
very much and uh
it is an honor to be here with my
brothers and sisters on the problem
solvers caucus
and doing this important work and i
commend all of them for what they did to
put this package together
um as they made clear to you the economy
is struggling
the hospitals are struggling and really
basically it's on fire right now
and it's like a fireman at a firehouse
here's a fire alarm going off and again
and again and again
and chooses to polish a fire truck and
so the next time it goes out it looks
better
we got to stop doing that we've got time
to act is now
and i just urge our leaders on both
sides of the aisle to put down their
swords
once and for all get this package done
and make it a good christmas for
everybody to know give them some hope
that
things are going to get better time time
for talking is over time to act is now
thank you and let me introduce to you
alyssa slotkin
um hi everyone um i echo um the comments
of my colleagues we had this amazing
tiger team that worked their butts off
to get to this proposal
um and we all owe them a debt of
gratitude um
and i stand in front of you today
basically with equal parts
pride and frustration pride that the
problem solvers caucus came together
in a bipartisan bicameral way to come up
with another proposal for coveted relief
but in doing so i acknowledge that i'm
also deeply frustrated
with what has led us to this point three
months ago in august when negotiations
stalled
between the white house the senate and
the house many of us in this bipartisan
caucus started talking about coming
together to come up with our own
proposal a group of people worked very
hard
so that in september we were able to
stand at this exact same podium
to kick start negotiations with the
proposal due to that work
we did jump start those negotiations and
i took a lot of pride in that
unfortunately election politics got in
the way and all three legs of the stool
the white house the house and the senate
leadership own a part of that failure
since that time the situation has got
precipitously worse
across the country seven million
americans have gotten sick and 75 000
have died in those three months
that we have been negotiating in
michigan alone we've seen a nine-fold
increase in daily cases
so i stand at the podium today with
another bipartisan proposal
this one this time it wasn't just the
house and a bipartisan proposal it
includes the senate
and i again feel pride now we can all
outline the reasons
why this is so desperate um as uh my
colleague fred upton said
the five hospitals in my district are at
or near
full capacity food banks have never been
busier
our restaurants hospitality industry our
small businesses are facing
oblivion and our mission right now
is to witness these stories and do
something about it
for everyone who has platitudes about
what the country is going through
you should be asking them specifically
what have they done today to actually
move us forward toward a compromise
if they're just offering platitudes and
they haven't come and joined us
signed up and endorsed the proposal and
said they're going to stay here until we
get this done
whatever it does to their christmas
break then they are talking
empty words with nothing behind it
it is no consequence to an icu nurse or
a small business owner
to just have those empty words um what
they care about is us getting together
and
fulfilling our mission to pass a bill i
thank my colleagues here for stepping up
and finding common ground i urge
leadership on all sides to make the same
commitment that people are making at
home
every single day which is waking up and
finding a way to muscle through this
crisis
we owe that to them we owe it to the
country thanks very much
and mr carbajal
each one of us goes back to our district
and hears the same thing over and over
in recent months
our workers are swelling the ranks of
unemployed
our businesses are going under
our schools are still closed our
families are food insecure
many facing eviction our hospitals are
swelling
with patients we have a sense of urgency
here
and we need to get beyond the gridlock
that defines this institution that we
are all part of
i couldn't be prouder of my colleagues
the problem solvers caucus who have
worked to find common ground
to provide a framework for our
leaderships on both sides of the aisle
to make it easier for them to move
forward and
take action now too many people are
hurting
we need to act today this is a down
payment on continued
support that the american people and my
district are going to need to be able to
get beyond this pandemic
both for our public health and our
economy
so we need to act now and again i'm very
grateful for all the work that everybody
has
put into this proposal
and next i'd like to introduce
representative horn
thank you very much i want to begin by
echoing my gratitude for this
this group of people for the problem
solvers since the very beginning
of this pandemic and even before then we
have come together
to bring proposals forward that are
timely that are targeted and transparent
and meet the needs
of our communities as many of my
colleagues have said
hospitals in my district are at capacity
we have external tents and temporary
structures being set up right now
because of the place
that we are in this pandemic our
businesses are hurting our communities
are suffering
and quite frankly it's inexcusable that
we have done
nothing since the cares act we
are the people that you see behind me
who have been consistently reaching
across the aisle
bringing proposals forward to address
the very real issues that are
happening in our communities and the
only way that we're going to do this
is together magical thinking and
promises
down the road don't help the families
who are hungry
the people who are suffering we have to
take action and we have to do it now we
simply cannot wait any longer
and i want to echo the comments of
everyone here who has said we
should not leave we will not leave until
this is done
and to thank all of the tiger team and
the leaders
for this work that is for the american
people
the bipartisan solutions that it's going
to take
for us to show up and serve our
communities
i'm dedicated to it and i know every
single person up here is as well
and that's what we should be asking for
from those who are elected to serve us
thank you and up next is
bill johnson
american families are hurting businesses
are hurting
i'm not going to reiterate and repeat
everything that you've heard from my
colleagues
but i'm honored to stand with the
problem solvers
to solve this problem this is not the
first time
that the problem solvers have come to
the table with the negotiating framework
to solve it
we should not go home until we get this
done
that's what the american people sent us
here to do
and i stand with my colleagues to make
sure we do
i think next we have uh my colleague mr
brendisi
thank you well i am not the shortest
problem solver but i will offer the
shortest comments
this package i'm not pointing anyone out
this package represents two simple words
common sense
and that's what the problem solvers do
best we bring people together to solve
big problems
that affect the american people and as i
talk to my constituents before they go
to bed every night the things they're
worried about
is how they're going to put food on the
table how they're going to help their
their children meet the challenges of
distance learning
how they're going to get a job if their
restaurant closes down for a second time
so i'm proud to support this package i
urge my colleagues to support this in
both houses
let's go home and deliver for the
american people thank you
next i'd like to introduce tom
o'halleran
hey kathy well here we are
we left in august we left before
thanksgiving
hopefully we won't leave before
christmas
and as we said we will be here
but and i agree with everything that's
been said about the problem solvers
about their leadership the tiger team
but our hearts go out to the people in
the healthcare community they're trying
to
weather this storm 16-hour days
lack of equipment this has been going on
for month after month after month
the frustration that you've seen from
them
is just unbelievable i'm one of the
older ones here
maybe the oldest
unless he's going to be 75 in january
i uh sign up for medicare i'm on it
i just want to say this we cannot
continue to see our neighbors and
friends and fellow americans die like
this
we cannot see fellow americans and their
families torn apart
and we cannot do anything that will hurt
our health care system anymore and as i
said on the floor earlier today
we gotta take care of this damn problem
hi
before he drops the mic let me go to joe
cunningham thanks
uh first of all i want to thank uh tom
reed and josh guy hummer for leading
this
this bipartisan coalition and and just
thank you for your friendship as well
um you know i think it's safe to say we
find ourselves an unprecedented times
right now
a global pandemic that's claimed the
lives of 274 thousand
americans you know our economy is in
desperate straits people are losing
loved ones
businesses are shuttering and meanwhile
politicians
continue pointing fingers these times
beg for strong leadership bipartisanship
for is that way of thinking
that will deliver our country from these
very troubling times
you know you've heard a little bit about
what this agreement is but with my
limited time i just want to
speak to the group that crafted it and
the need for it during such highly
charged partisan times
in our country you see our country is as
divided as it's ever been
and what i've seen here in my short
tenure is that our politics are
completely toxic
and washington is more gridlocked than
any time in recent history
but during these turbulent times this
group the problem solvers caucus
has been a beacon of hope and otherwise
very
very dark environment this is a group
that knows that
the other party is not the enemy the
enemy is a stubbornness of our own
biases
the enemy is a political culture that
seeks to divide us
just for sport instead of fighting each
other
we should be fighting for each other we
should be fighting
to change the culture that has polluted
our politics and divided
our country for far too long we have to
start talking to each other again
and most importantly we've got to start
listening to each other again
you know i've been told that tree
becomes stronger as it it's exposed to
to winds because the horror the wind
blows
the trees roots will extend deeper into
the ground reaching further into the
earth to make it more stable
and make it stronger that's nature
i tell you that because it's similar
elsewhere too and it's true of this
particular group
because as the partisanship wins blow
harder here in d.c
it's groups like this they will dig in
expand their routes
allowing the tree of democracy to be
stronger
more stable and able to withstand any
political storm
leaders bipartisan leaders like the one
standing behind me
make our democracy stronger and i simply
feel honored
to be counted among them thank you
well in a sign of effectiveness i hope
um as we were standing here it has been
bought to my attention uh
that uh the president just uh issued a
statement saying he is in support
of our 900-plus billion dollar package
uh so we are now come on
we're going to declare a moment of
optimism here in front of the capitol
but the bottom line is with with that
support
that there's recognition that this is a
package that needs to get signed into
law
that the american people need this
relief and that these members are
standing together
as democrats and as republicans but as
we opened up with
as proud americans it is time for this
institution to do its job and as we said
we are not leaving until that signature
is on this package
and that relief is flowing and it's
because of the members
that are standing here before you as
true american leaders
questions so the spirit of common sense
i'll take your questions
has anyone gotten a commitment from the
president or anyone in the white house
that he would be on board with this not
a publisher
so what we have always prided ourselves
on in the problem service caucus is we
keep our leadership
as well as our relationship with the the
white house
those communications we keep them
apprised as to what we're working on and
what we're
doing and so throughout this entire
process
what we have been talking about when we
got to this agreement
we knew this was in the zone of what
they would uh be in a position to
support
now as we put the final details together
obviously the details matter
and so i would anticipate until that
final detail package is out there we'll
get a
the formal commitment uh of support from
all the players uh that you're talking
about but that being said a public
indication
from the white house a public indication
from our leadership in the house in
regards to
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer as well
as now
momentum building on both sides of the
of the aisle
bodes well for the fact that this is the
package that moved the needle
to get people to say we would support
this level of support
going out to the american people so that
i think that is a very positive
development
and i would take it as a positive sign
that now we just have to get the final
details
etched out into agreement go ahead and
then we're
we have not heard there similar
commitment from mcconnell or mccarthy
would it be fair to say the bonus is now
on them to come to the table and endorse
this is that the next step that needs to
happen
well maybe on our side just when you
have the president now coming out
and moving in the direction of this uh
proposal and you saw the democratic
leadership moving in the direction of
this proposal
we're in the zone and we knew through
the conversations
that going back and forth and truly
listening to each other that 900 billion
dollars
was where that common ground uh was and
so
uh you know i think we're going to get
there and let's just defer to them as to
how
they're going to respond to that direct
question but i will tell you i'm very
confident
uh given now the nature of the
developments that we're there and i'm
just saying the key here is
908 which is the number we've been
focused on as you know
and and driving toward where we've been
able to find both
support in the house and the senate and
the priorities underneath
it right it's not just it's not just the
number it's also what's what we agreed
to as you and you all know the outlines
of the package
uh so i think those priorities have to
be we'll continue to be
front and center and as we have these
discussions and draft legislation in the
next day or two
and i i promise that gentleman and then
we'll go over here to follow up on his
question have you had any conversations
with mcconnell or his team
and what have they been like because he
has made very clear that he is still
focused on his targeted bill
so you know obviously we keep them
apprised as to what we're doing
uh we're having conversations like i
mentioned with corey gardner and we've
been talking to
leadership in the in the senate as well
as their teams
um obviously we get we're public
positioning and
and what they have to do so we won't
speak for them and we keep those
conversations the detailed conversations
private
because that's important to our
credibility and the ability to do the
business that we do
in getting people to find that common
ground and talk to each other so
i'll defer to them as to where they end
up but i will just tell you
when you see people and the momentum
going in the right direction
i think uh time in short order will show
that we're in the area where we're going
to land this plane
lindsey on the democratic side schumer
policing their statement
said that they want more money in
since proposal including more money for
state and local and vaccine distribution
have they given you any specifics
beyond that as to what improvements they
want to see and
if you think that that's feasible who's
working on those improvements
well i spoke to the speaker this morning
again we continue to have conversations
and and we had meetings with our our
group with our senate colleagues this
morning
i think everybody i i really believe
we're very very close
the language of course as tom just said
is critically important it's what we're
working on now in the bill
and i think that that some of the
debates will will you know find their
way onto those pages as we wrap this up
uh but i i believe or i think from
from the feedback i've gotten is we're
just about there
the question now is in the language of
the bill making sure that we
put on the page gets onto those pages
so are they at the table with you guys
now writing the actual text
because they said this could be a basis
for factual
i'll offer two things um you know
obviously we've been at this for
many months in regards to uh um the the
framework that you see here in the 908
billion dollar
proposal so legislative text has been
floating out there in pieces
so that text is out there if you would
and staff has been doing yeoman's work
in regards to working with us on a
a day-to-day basis and a tireless basis
to
put this together and so i i think
you'll see the text be built we're
trying to shoot for over the weekend
here as we
uh try to land this plane but the bottom
line is i'm not concerned about the text
so much being
a delay uh issue because so much time
has been prepared
and dedicated to that as we speak and
you were gonna that's right
given the positive reaction you're
getting from both sides of the aisle
do you see that as a sign that in the
next congress on fiscal issues
moderates could have more influence
compared to this section of congress
well i believe i'll just say that common
sense will be
what dictates in the next congress and i
think the idea
this this model of how we're working
together to me is exactly the model
to get things done in the next congress
right and and democrats and republicans
coming together not just here
but obviously given the narrow
majorities working together with our
senate colleagues
so now i'm not thinking i'm trying not
to focus on next year we got to focus on
getting this done now
and and but i think this is the model
with how we actually can get things done
versus people screaming at each other
and yelling at each other you know this
is the right approach
you know as you know everything's about
putting things down and trying to get it
and trying to get what you can get and
we've been working around the clock as
tom has said with this group behind us
for weeks there's things we'd all
there's things we'd all like more of but
the bottom line is
um we believe you're talking whether
you're talking about helping people
um with with unemployment whether you're
talking about nutrition and making sure
those who
as dean showed this show in the picture
you've got people with the first time
in the food lines and making sure we've
got support in there for them and for
our schools
and for child care and for rental
assistance so many of the priorities
that we all care about
are are and the police we believe in and
fight for
are in on this 908 and i believe that's
going to
be what we're going to fight for in the
next days to make sure that that's what
happens
all right i think one last question
once the new administration comes in i
mean
i i think that this i look at this as a
down payment and we're going to see as
as tom and i have talked about we're
going to see and the whole group where
the country is of course
uh in the in the new administration what
our focus here is an emergency
short-term package to get us through uh
a very tough time
in our country to get us into that get
us through the first quarter next year
into a new administration i mean i think
there's going to be a lot a lot more
help that's needed
but the bottom line is for now what
we're focused on is making sure we don't
go home
we don't leave here until we actually
deliver and that will continue to be our
focus in the days ahead thanks guys
all right thank you everyone
that's fine
he was never
you guys want to be excited
do you think i can take this list just
for one yeah um i have extras too if you
don't want the one that was written all
over
that one's the most accurate